[Musique]
bonsoir
je crois que c'est le moment le plus
stressant pour moi
c'est très sain parce qu'en fait on se
pose toujours la question de comment
est-ce qu'on va commencer un toc alors
du coup première chose qu'on fait c'est
qu'on va voir d'autres vidéos de theix
et on se rend compte de plusieurs choses
d'abord
pour sujet a déjà été traité plusieurs
fois train des personnes bien plus
compétentes que moi
donc du coup juste derrière on se pose
la question des crises que je vais
pouvoir bien raconté de plus que ces
visionnaires professionnels professeurs
qui ont tous des choses super
intéressante et intelligente à dire
j'avoue que je me suis posée exactement
la même question hier soir dans la
répétition générale
ces questions en fait sont l'incarnation
parfaite de ce qu'on peut appeler le
syndrome de l'imposteur ne pas se sentir
assez bons pour faire ou mérité quelque
chose
en résumé tout le monde est plus
intelligent plus beau plus fort que soi
et parfois il ya une autre incarnation
en fait vous pouvez imaginer une sorte
de présence et une voix qu'ils avouent
dire genre imposteur
qu'est ce tu l'as dit encore là après là
on commence un peu à stresser mains
moites on parle plus rapidement on
commence à bouger sur la scène on a
envie de partir
enfin bon ce que je suis en train de
traverser actuellement
non j'ai toujours vécu avec ce syndrome
parce que j'ai toujours eu de gros
problèmes de confiance en moi que ça
soit à travers mon adolescence où mes
études j'ai toujours eu cette voix qui
m'empêchait de m'exprimer parfois me
censurer
mais c'est quand j'ai été refusé en
doctorat que je me suis posé la question
de en fait pourquoi est ce que je me
sentais aussi bête alors qu'en théorie
je ne devrait pas l'être
finalement qu'est-ce que c'est en tire
un poster pas en fait c'est estimer en
partie que nos connaissances ou
compétences sont inférieurs par rapport
à celles des autres
alors à l'époque je sortais d'un master
2 en biologie intégrative et physiologie
avec une spécialité en neuroscience
cognitive et comportementale
13 ans sur les bancs d'école donc ni vos
connaissances en théorie ce qui devrait
gérer
alors je me suis lancé dans l'exercice
qui fait probablement l'exercice le plus
débile de toute ma vie
essayez de faire un état des lieux de
mes connaissances
alors je n'ai jamais réussi à remplir un
kit est une feuille d'incarner à 5 et
pour quelqu'un accusé de faire ça pour
prendre confiance en soi je vous avoue
que je suis traîné avec total et je le
conseille à personne vraiment
mais derrière cette réflexion m'a amené
une autre question qui était mais qu'est
ce que c'est que ce avoir quelque chose
en dhr est biologiquement parlant
concrètement une connaissance ça
ressemble à quoi
alors j'ai fait quelques recherches et
je suis arrivé très vite à une première
hypothèse
il n'y aurait pas de connaissances
stockés dans notre tête en tout cas pas
sous la forme dont on pense on imagine
toujours notre cerveau comme une sorte
d'ordinateur dans lequel il y aurait un
disque dur et sur lesquels on stocke de
l'information vous voyez plus votre
cerveau comme
gigantesque complexe et super bordélique
réseau électrique et chacun des câbles
qui se croit ces milliards de câbles en
fait créer des mini réseau et sur ses
mines et réseaux sont stockés des
concepts des mots des lettres
pour imaginer je peux vous vous souvenez
de quelqu'un d'un objet ou quoi que ce
soit en fait vous imaginez ces réseaux
qui s'allument dans vos têtes
mais ces réseaux ne sont pas fixes il
secret il se connecte il se déconnecte
et il se transforme au gré du temps
vous apprenez quelque chose un réseau et
créé le réseau démantelé où la mémoire
qui attache et disparaît
et la seule condition pour repérer cette
magie qu'on appelle la place cités
plasticité cérébrale est tout simplement
de faire rentrer et circuler de
l'électricité dans le système
et ça
c'est le rôle des sens
vos yeux bonnet votre langue votre peau
tous possèdent des micros cellules dont
la fonction première est tout simplement
de transformer des informations de
l'environnement
en signaux électriques et faire émerger
des mots des sons des souvenirs chacune
de vos pensées est en fait le résultat
de vague électrique qui traverse votre
cerveau de bord en bord
des cars 2 disait je pense donc je suis
est peut-être qu'on pourrait rajouter
avant je sens donc je pense donc je suis
une information ne peut vraiment existé
dans la tête que si elle est chargée de
sens
la seconde condition pour que cette
information soit fixée et surtout
renforcer à travers le temps et tout
simplement qu'elles soient traduites en
actions alors c'est un peu comme si
l'action était le dernier noeud
nécessaires pour maintenir défilent
ensemble
je suis en train de dire c'est qu'en
fait le cerveau ne fait attention qu à
l'apprendre pas le faire
du coup on peut continuer notre travail
sur des cartes je sens donc je pense
donc je suis donc je fais
l'environnement conditionne ma façon de
penser qui conditionne mon être et
conditionne mes actes et par extension
en comportement
il m'arrivait ce type de trucs quand on
a beaucoup de connaissances on apprend
par coeur je vous avais été très bons
pour ça-
une information voire une connaissance
ne peut donc être maintenue en mémoire
qu'à partir du moment où elle était
forgé à travers une expérience
prenons un exemple
le week-end dernier j'étais en train
d'apprendre à faire du vélo à ma fille
j'ai beau lui expliquer tous les
concepts du monde prends ton vélo demain
sur le guidon ok pose ton pied
maintenant le pied sur la [ __ ]
attention regarde devant pouce devant
équilibre qui déséquilibre elle n'a
réussi à faire des progrès qu à partir
du moment
où je les laisser faire laisser tomber
l'essai se relever pleurer
et c'est au moment où elle a fait trente
mètres tout seul elle a freiné toute
seule elle s'est retournée à m'a
regardée et là j'ai sur moi j'étais
complètement essoufflé mais là j'ai su
que dans cet échange de regards que
cette mémoire à l'aide scellé à jamais
dans son esprit et vous savez ce qu'on
dit sur la prendre à vélo on n'oublie
jamais
à prendre par l'expérience permet tout
simplement de connecter les choses entre
elles elle permet de créer un lien de
cause à effet une logique et ça pourrait
être d'ailleurs la définition de
comprendre je comprend quelque chose
parce que ce fin où je pense comprendre
quelque chose parce que cela est logique
pour moi cela a du sens pour moi
dans les médias en parlent beaucoup
d'apprendre à apprendre mais peut-être
que finalement la clé ça serait
d'apprendre à comprendre
alors du coup dans cette histoire les
connaissances qu'est ce que ça serait
pas une connaissance en fait ça serait
une hypothèse nécessaire pour
généraliser d expérience une
connaissance c'est en fait une
probabilité qu'il va se passer quelque
chose si je fais quelque chose en
d'autres termes c'est un truc du genre
peut-être que c'est vrai mais peut-être
que c'est faux et la seule façon de le
savoir c'est d'expérimenter
et si le résultat de mon expérience
confirme alors la probabilité que cette
connaissance soit juste augmente c'est
le rapport qu'on voit dans les sciences
expérimentales et sciences théorique
des expériences permettent de générer
une théorie cette théorie permet de
guider de nouvelles expériences et ses
expériences permettre d'ajuster
confirmer ou réfuter une théorie
qu'est ce que ça veut dire parfaite ça
veut dire que tout ce que je viens juste
de vous dire eh ben il probablement faux
c'est à ce stade ce sont que des
hypothèses pour vous qui devront être
confronté à vos expériences passées et
futures pour savoir si vous validez ou
pas c'est ce qu'on appelle l'esprit
critique
avec tout ça
j'avais enfin réussi à trouver une
solution pour apprendre de nouvelles
choses sans avoir à lire un livre
j'allais apprendre par expérience alors
j'ai continué à explorer la danse le
cinéma la photo le design en partie l
architecture l'entrepreneuriat et ainsi
de suite chaque nouvelle expérience me
servait de base pour construire une
nouvelle et plus expérimenté plus les
concepts prenez du sens pour moi et
surtout j'arrivais à les faire connecter
et à les mettre en relation et cette
mise en relation me permettait de faire
générer des idées mes propres idées mes
propres connaissances et surtout de les
assumer
ce monde d'expériences me permit de
reprendre confiance en moi enfin
à 35 ans paul
mais au moment où j'ai réussi à prendre
confiance pour partager mes idées
et ben en fait j'ai une super douche
froide
ah oui tu as étudie les neurosciences
maintenant du coup tu dois bien
connaître tes théories de la physique
cognitives aléatoire du professeur de
rubrique
non mais par contre quand j'étais
serveurs j'ai observé oui tu as été
serveur alors il ya un podcast génial
sur les serveurs le philosophe conti qui
parle du rôle de serveur dans la
sociologie organisée franchement tu
devrais écouter quoi
apostats
je crois que j'étais parti quelques pas
ou quoi
mais la question qu'il faut se poser
c'est pourquoi est ce qu'on fait ça
moi le premier pourquoi est-ce que dès
qu'on entend quelque chose qui nous
sommes intelligents on s'empresse à le
transférer à quelqu'un d'autre comme si
on on s'approprie un peu de cette vij
ans si je cite quand est ce que ça veut
dire que j'ai le même niveau de
connaissance de cause parce que ça veut
dire que je suis aussi intelligent quand
d'abord est ce que quand tu es
intelligent la personne ne le sait
est-ce que je cite quand
pour t'aider à comprendre quelque chose
ou est ce que je cite quand juste pour
me la péter et puis d'ailleurs j'ai pas
de me donner la vie de quand je
demandais de ton avis à toi si je vous
laisse chercher ce que penser quand je
répare son compte instagram
s'effondra pression est vraiment mon
impression mais j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui nous vivons dans une
société qui est basée sur la
valorisation des connaissances des
autres plutôt que la valorisation de nos
propres expériences c'est un peu comme
si la société vous pousser à pas prendre
confiance en soi
j'ai pas en train de dire qu'il faut pas
lire ni écouter des podcasts ni est
partagée au contraire le partage de la
connaissance reste quand même la clé de
l'accélération des sociétés
tout ce que je dis c'est que des
connaissances doivent servir pour guider
les curiosités animé les conversations
et stimuler les choses non pas comme une
arme de soumission ou de valorisation
sociale
je pense que j'ai commencé cette
aventure pour faire pas que j'étais
quelqu'un de spécial
que moi aussi je pouvais être un intello
merkel ma faible culture générale
mais plus j'avance plus je crois que
superman
[Musique]
et par banal j'entends tout simplement
pas plus intelligent ou plus bêtes que
les autres
on peut tous faire émerger nos propres
connaissances nos propres idées de nos
expériences
la seule question c'est de pouvoir les
assumer en son propre nom pour les
partager et les cultiver
et je pense que c'est ce que j'ai essayé
de faire ce soir notant qu'un pasteur ou
penseurs mais pour une fois
juste en tant que guillaume deschamps
benoît mercier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]